yeah I'm so happy to see you guys after
I've seen the movie - that's out by
screening was oh my god I will ever feel
electricity and they are quite like that
thus I don't you know you will we were
just talking about that the other day of
how like insane we felt and I was like
shaking and crying and laughing all at
the same time it really was just a
magical well deserved so I have two
games for you guys for that but the
first thing we want to do here is kind
of take a little trip down memory lane
at school and we're gonna do so with the
ultimate piece of nostalgia I'm gonna
hasty you got it okay wait do you want
to do it ultimate so you do we could
switch off here see ya guys play it
through and then there's a letter
underneath and I am the corresponding
question on 8686 3e were you ever sent
to the principal's office or what was
the most trouble you ever gotten
I was never sent to the principal's was
never sent because in the library but I
needed this back I had my book open once
because I was like a little nervous
about this test and I got in trouble for
having the book open
when you do it you use it okay you're
Orange I'm Orange wait I just started
going that's easy four five seven hey
have you ever thrown a house party for
my 16 no no no sorry 7:15 who's my 15 it
all sixteenth was also a house party yes
or not but not like no one was drinking
again very respectable answers you're
kidding when we said we told you're not
wild anything we haven't broken any
rules name one person whose life was so
much better because they broke a couple
of rules ah so he broke our rules Rosa
Parks Eamonn Ellis was in the Anthony
goddammit
did you ever I think I know the answer
to this did you ever cheat on a test bed
and now I have you've done it once yeah
even if you don't need to it's like the
feeling I'm just like see the anxiety we
caught me Tim and what happened I lead
you're not getting more trouble for that
but no he he likes at me down and he
liked talk to me out and he gave me a
zero on it and then oh I knew it
I mean wow
let's do zero
why did you guys want to be when you
were kid wow I wanted to be a weather
woman and then I realized when I was
like three I wanted a Doppler I was one
of those kids that just wanted to act my
entire life I know that's like a boring
answer I literally wanted to act my
whole life what's the class you took in
school that has come in the least handy
today science like your mad science er
oh no Matt Matt Matt snow you need math
no statistics is helpful in life art
history I love it but like do you need
it I mean yeah science I would say
science yeah
chemistry I'll never get it though
[Music]